welcome to a video on code tech and
tutorials my name is Matt I will be your
host today and I am going to show you
how to do the native unit tests on your
C++ static libraries so I'm just gonna
set up a basic example and go through it
and hopefully that helps you all out so
I've opened Visual Studio I get the
default project thing I'm gonna click
create a new project this is just Visual
Studio 2019 Community Edition updated as
of today there's the date and time it's
often handy to know when a tutorial was
done cuz you can figure out versions
better just want to do an empty well we
could even do a static library let's
just start out with static library so
we're not doing the universal Windows
one just the plain old C++ static
library so let's go ahead and we'll name
it the the usual test or the usual
example people give is math because math
functions are easy to put into a static
library so we could go with that maybe
we'll be a little more specific and
we'll say math stuff that's not a little
more specific or whatever I'm going with
it all right so I got my location where
I like it you put yours where you like
it of course and just click create it
pre-generated us some headers and some
source files and the only one I really
want to look at is this math stuff
function so this is an example of a
library function it says defines
functions for the static library so if
we go to this math stuff and right click
on it and go to properties we'll see
that it is a static library
configuration type OOP so I've changed
in static library so the static library
doesn't run on its own even if I hit
play it's gonna come up with a thing
that says what are you doing there it is
unable to start program it's not a valid
win32 application so static libraries
just in case you don't know I'm gonna
try to over explain rather than under
explain static libraries aren't ran on
their own they're usually linked to
another program the actual application
our executable when it's compiled you
link this library to it that way and you
can get its functionality and use it in
your code and stuff this doesn't do
anything we'll just do make a and add
we'll just make a plain ol to add and
it's just gonna take so it's just gonna
be an integer adder it's not gonna be
anything too fancy and of course we want
to design it's just going to return and
of course these need to be different I'm
one time to this is kind of get the job
done but of course you could do all
sorts of things to make a little more
efficient etc so we'll do an ad and
we'll do a subtract
just put those right in there I guess we
could make a comment here that says it
subtract two from one and that might pop
up another editor and tell us so that
could be handy for later it's it's just
gonna do just a little comment there all
right so now we've got enough to have a
couple functions that we can just test
the basic functionality of but how do we
make our tests and that's where the real
subject of this video comes in and I'm
gonna go to this top solution here right
click and do a add new project so that's
what you want to do you basically want
to add a new project in your solution
there's other ways to do it - I think
you can do it right here at the end file
add new project so you can do it any of
those ways and you want to get to this
add a new project and look for native
unit test project you'll see it looks
like this and it's to write C++ unit
tests using the native microsoft cpp
unit test frame work so this is the
Microsoft sea repeat unit test framework
and that's what we're gonna look at
there's a lot of different test
frameworks out there catch two is a
popular one Google test is another
popular one this is the Microsoft CPP
unit test framework that just comes with
Visual Studio
it's generically good enough to be fine
for your stuff if this is what you're
using alright so once a name for our
test we'll just do unit tests basic man
we'll do basic math that's fine actually
meant to have my camera on I had to plug
in my light okay there we go all right
so we're looking at this new unit test
of basic math and to run this you
basically go up to the top here and go
to test and run all tests it doesn't let
us right now because I think we need to
compile first or maybe we just need to
add a test method well if we want to
test out these functions we'll do some
basic asserts so we'll do assert I am
missing a few things on purpose I just
want to show you the basics of what you
need to do okay so in this I'm in this
unit test basic math talk.cpp file that
it automatically created and I just want
to do an assert are equal and you can
hit control space to get some
autocomplete and see everything here and
let's just do a basic add let's get a
are equal four and the add function that
we created with two and two so yeah
let's just make sure that comes back as
we want as you can see it's red and
confused it doesn't understand it that's
because we need to link the library and
to do that we just go to our unit test
basic math and go to add reference and
the reference we want to add is our math
stuff static library we're back to here
and it still doesn't quite understand
this ad says it's undefined and we
really want to include a CPP
no no that sounds like a terrible idea
we want to include a header with these
functions normally because if the only
way we can get to these functions or see
them is by including a CPP that's not
very good for a static library
what header do you include or should it
automatically do it based on the linker
it won't automatically do it based on
linkers that's at compile time so
there's no good header to include by
default when you when you just use
visual Studios default setup so let's
just make a header file for now and
we're gonna call this math stuff dot H
so it's gonna match with this CPP file
and there is this math stuff is
basically gonna have nothing in it so
we're going to just cut all that and put
it up here in the header we want an
object to be for it to be able to
compile into and that is gonna be this
here we're just need to include the
header could even do it in the PCH if we
include math stuff here so we could even
get rid of this altogether yeah let's
just get rid of yeah let's do delete so
you're rid of the CPP altogether we've
already got a CPP we really only need
one now that we have it defined in an H
and I don't think we want these multiple
times we just want it in our framework
or in our and this one as well
so we'll do include math stuff and now
it should compile into the precompiled
CPP okay let's see if that works let's
see if it's happy we still got this this
add function but now we have a proper
header to include and that is this
masked up header you know what let's
let's do something a little fancy it's
to link to it it's gonna have to go back
a directory and then in the masked up
and math stuff side H we can make that a
little cleaner I mean that'll work I'll
be fine as you can see it's now happy
but you can make that a little cleaner
by putting the includes putting it on
the includes as well in this VCC
directories you could basically just say
okay let's start with the solution
directory and then it already has a
slash and then we want that stuff folder
and now it should be a little easier to
include because we can just do it like
so thingamajigger
alright so now when we go up to test and
run tests it still doesn't let us why
isn't the lightest this should be fine
now let's see if our test builds
successfully it seems to so we should be
able to do it now let's go into our test
Explorer it's now seen him I don't know
why it took so long but I had to go into
the test Explorer or to like to do the
scan but now this is set up so that's a
little obscure something that people
might be stuck on how do you run your
tests when you're when this is grayed
out yeah I can see people running into
that and it looks like you just got to
go into this test Explorer first and
then you can even do it from here run
all tests let's go ahead and run it and
we should get a new outcome and it
passed so our basic Edition from our
static library is working fine and now
you can add to these tests and change
them up as much as you want so we'll
call this first one add tests we'll just
rename it and if we want to make another
test method I just did a copy there with
selecting highlighting it hit hidden
ctrl D we'll just call this one add the
test method add and subtract and we can
run as many little R equals and asserts
in there as we want so we'll do is
subtract here two minus two should be
zero
and there we go we probably need to do a
new compile for this to be happy just do
a build does not take two arguments what
did I get something wrong I must do
something wrong in this messed up
library oh these uh these words are
interacting with the namespace and
bugging out so I can't name this
subtract because it thinks I'm talking
about this function and same with this
add so this actually highlights a point
about these about your libraries and you
should have them in some sort of
namespace space so you don't get all
those collisions so we'll call this name
space well math is also a very common
one so maybe I'll call it something else
it's like just math stuff I guess
and we'll just encapsulate that there we
go now that they're in a namespace this
should be a little bit happier because
it's not going to be so confused but we
do have to scope these to the namespace
here where we're actually wanting the
functions and now it's happy because it
doesn't think that these are the
functions we can actually give them
those basic names let's go ahead and run
these tests again so now our little
testing up there actually is a running
working fine so it's not run why not run
them okay it's quick it again I must
have not clicked it I think I must want
to just Explorer but it looks like it
passes on both of those and now we could
add as many tests as we want we could
change things up and see if it fails so
we could do something that is just wrong
and it's so that it's never for you know
we can do whatever in our test you can
have as many tests as you want and
usually when you're testing you
generally want to try to cover all the
given scenarios that could possibly
happen with your code and mass that's
very large so you might just do like a
large case a really small case and a
couple in between or something like that
and just confirm that those all work so
it's often good to have one that presses
pushes the limit in either direction and
just see how far you can go anyway
that's how you do
it let me know if you have any questions
trying to think of anything that I might
need to say that could be important but
I think I've covered the majority of it
I think it's pretty obvious how to
expand these literally just make more
functions like divide just make
Associated tests for them like so if I -
should be one and of course we got to go
design this function because right now
it's a - and that's a terrible one to
test with to be honest because uh
divisions pretty different in C++ in
case you didn't know you get the remand
remainder or the modulo factor so this
of course if it wouldn't if there was a
fraction it would just probably floor it
I don't even know depends what it feels
like doing or yeah it probably depends
on Pilate I haven't tested that recently
but we're not gonna get into that that's
that's another thing this is all about
how to make these tests I think you guys
get it so now if we ran this test we'd
get the result of our divide in there as
well and if you want to do more of these
tests you can just keep adding them and
building that reference so just add
another project another native test and
this way you can have tests for
different areas
unit tests you know - is fine so you can
basically make a bunch of different
tests and run certain ones and all that
stuff you can just manage it all in one
big project and it's kind of cool ok so
yes it would be the same thing with the
second one I'm sure you guys have got it
right now I'm just gonna do this as an
outro thank you so much for watching
don't forget to like if you liked this
video and subscribe it does help a lot
as we're trying to win the YouTube war I
don't know what that means but yeah
everything everything does mean a lot to
me so I do really appreciate it and
but you might have a test for another
library you can have multiple libraries
all within your project you can have
multiple tests you can have multiple
executables just as possible with Linux
and your own custom setup with make
files and stuff cuz that's kind of how I
learned but just being able to do it all
within an editor and it all working
generally pretty good is very nice very
very excellent for development in
general so that's why I think it's
important to make these videos and show
the basics if you've ever heard of
test-driven development that's kind of
what this is about - you make the tests
and then you build the code to pass all
the tests and then in theory you have
all the functions you need for what
you're trying to do pretty cool right
assert our I'll just we'll just do a not
equal or something
two and three it's not equal not a thing
are not equal okay so there we go we can
run our second one you can build it do
essentially the same thing tests run all
tests and we get this unit test and this
unit tests so there we go
and they're both passing obviously
because it's a very straightforward
stuff and it all seems to be working
well peace out you guys stay safe out
there alright see you guys in the next
episode and peace out